اوروبيا انقلت رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه
ارسل ان علاقه الاتحاد الاوروبي مع الصين
ستكون رهنا بموقف بيجين من حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا
على الصين كعضو دائم في مجلس الامن ان
تطلع بدور لحمايه القيم والمبادئ التي هي
في صميم ميثاق الامم المتحده وعليها ان
تقوم بدور لتحقيق السلام العادل والدائم
وكيف تتفاعل الصين مع الحرب في اوكرانيا
سيكون عاملا اساسيا في تحديد شكل العلاقه
بين اوروبا والصين نحن نرى بيجين تتخذ
قرارات حازمه في محيطها فهي تمارس سياسه
عرض العضلات في بحر جنوب الصين وعلى
حدودها مع الهند وهذا يهدد شركائنا
ومصالحهم كذلك نشدد على السلام والاستقرار
في مضيق تايوان واي اضعاف للاستقرار في
اسيا يؤثر على مصالحنا في تلك المنطقه